quel est le sens du carnaval dans notre
société
qui plus est en tant qu vide il peut
devenir un espace de transgression et
mis en chanson régadous le lundi le
mardi le mercredi le jeudi le vendredi à
dimanche ségo qu est ce que la chanson
créole en cours sa place dans le
carnaval aujourd'hui ce carnaval sa
chanson est considérée comme une cuisine
114 qu'est ce qui fait selon vous la
beauté de notre carnaval
nous avons un gros navale a menti nique
tout le monde participe
nous avons le val qui le roi vaval miss
sauval le carnaval sera un petit peu
triste ou nico vite dû ni tousser bayt
al ayni mathieu vous ferez vous fait
voir la voile sur macro et pourquoi
ah ça c'est important pour moi je serai
peut-être le préfet
nous avons un carnaval 2021 est un peu
particulier est ce que vous préparez
déjà le retour du carnaval comme il
était auparavant pour 2022 on est
toujours avec le temps avance sur la
préparation du carnaval prochain donc ça
veut dire qu'il ya cette forme
d'expression cette année due à la
circonstance
l'année prochaine on est déjà en train
de réfléchir parce qu'on s'imagine que
le confirme même s'il est là sa forme ne
sera pas éternelle
[Musique]